[Musik]
oder
das regionalgefängnis bern ist ein raues
pflaster
ihr leben kinderschänder mörder
[Musik]
735 verbrecher auf engstem raum
in dieser welt wo man das schlecht im
menschen vermutet fühlt sich marlies
panda zu hause hier beurteile gefällt
und vorurteile schwierig abzuschütteln
sind in dieser welt begegnet die
gefängnisdirektorin menschen deren taten
sie verabscheut kraft menschen die sie
dennoch schützen will
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor sieben uhr morgens paris
panda auf dem weg zu den aufmüpfigen ihm
saßen den ausschaffungshäftlinge aus dem
maghreb diese können sich zwar fünf
stunden pro tag auf ihrem stockwerk frei
bewegen trotzdem brodelt es jeder will
mit der direktorin sprechen und jeder
sofort
[Musik]
wissen sie sahen sie die schweiz
verlassen müssen
das weiß ich nicht aber ich weiß wie ich
in der schweiz bleiben kann
ich möchte meinen flug wechseln ich will
nach tunesien nicht nach italien
meine mutter ist kann
ich habe es verstanden aber ich habe die
kompetenz nicht
vielleicht können sie es ihm auf
arabisch übersetzt
ich kann keine flüge tauschen
aber sie können ihm helfen mit der
fremdenpolizei zu sprechen
aber die waren doch schon bei ihnen
das ist alles scheiße
moment ich
bin unter großem druck
helfen sie mir mit etwas geld
[Musik]
sehr anspruchsvoll
sofort
wiederum schafik saft sie sehe höre und
themen squeezy gehe unrechtmäßigen
kleines jedoch nicht nach natürlich
hätte sie bis gemacht aber sehe ich da
was illegales schweizer
csu abgelehnt worden ist und man darf
mit der gasse glühte vorgang ich dir
natürlich mehrere möglichkeiten zur
ausreise wenn sie natürlich ein wenig
oder illegales jahr zur schweizer werte
sehen die durch schafften
[Musik]
ein ganz anderes problem war doch die
gefängnisdirektorin in celle 205 die
ehefrau des häftlings ist vor ein paar
tagen gestorben während der wegen
diebstahls im gefängnis saß
marlies panda wird zur seelsorgerin
[Musik]
36 jahre lang waren die beiden ein
glückliches paar jetzt so ein ende
[Musik]
studienwoche
performte
marlies panda kümmert sich bereits um
einen anderen häftlingen
für jeden will sie ein offenes ohr haben
diese fürsorglichkeit dieser güte im
gefängnis mag manchen irritieren für
maries panda ist es der einzige weg um
erfolgreich zu sein
zu starker sozialstaat also die
hardliner
jeweils pro pc und die wolle dazu rossi
die mir bestätigt dass du die art wie
mehr jedes kleine leute auf ihre mit
weniger aggressionen
das regionalgefängnis bern ist eines der
größten gefängnisse der schweiz
135 plätze 54 mitarbeiter und mit über
12.000 ein und austritten pro jahr eine
drehscheibe im strafvollzug
jeden morgen steht er ab ort mit den
kader mitglieder das wichtigste am
heutigen tag die chronische überbelegung
und ein problem in der küche
acht jahre lang konfrontiert mit dem
bösen im menschen haben die
gefängnisdirektorin nicht mürbe gemacht
im gegenteil
sie kommen noch jeden tag mit freude zur
arbeit
ist positiv für anträge gibt bitten
massenparty startete
sagt positive an der ecke geht es oft
oft bares für übertrieben aber es geht
[Musik]
ein beispiel ist der insasse dieser
zelle ein bosnier vor zwei jahren ist
der wegen drohung und betrug ins
gefängnis gekommen anfänglich depressiv
und lethargisch reißt er sich heute als
erster um die sperre ich mache meine
arbeit
habe viel gelernt sagt der 38-jährige er
eine wette betrübt gewesen und pc mit
augen mit gesicht mache ich bin ganz
dank weiß was ihm ein
beispiel die schließung das ist einfach
sofort ihre etwas schließt
aber ich weiß werde ich das schiff darum
ich sehe wie meine zweite mut sie hat
seit wie normal eine herzliche was sie
will i be so kleine füße weh aber sie
nehme mit zeit für uns funk minute zehn
minuten das ist viel für uns
ist durch vorstellte sagen wir die
kultur ist sie
wurde das beispiel arabischer kultur icd
höhere stelle und die wm-dritte
mütterlicher typ und deshalb angeklagte
respekt vor den inseln
ihr problem
karubi die situation annika gefühlen zu
denen kuschel knirscht was hier ist das
wetter vorstellte sieht ihr sohn nach
linie zähler knapp im quadratmeter und
petter foul direkt feinstruktur das ist
immer kuschel knast probten für mich
wichtig dass man die respektiert um
bisher gedacht im
rosé für anna lindh ist dass wir neben
ihrer richtung das ist nicht wie sie das
machen andere
es ist wichtig dass wir im zeugnis
probieren aggressionen ab jetzt für
mieter und opa zu
provozieren
[Musik]
die meisten häftlinge sind 23 stunden am
tag eingesperrt in ihrer winzigen zelle
eine stunde pro tag dürfen sie den
spazierhof
und ja
in ihrem gemischtwarenladen die
direktorin sagt ist die mehrheit der
gefangenen in untersuchungshaft andere
verbüßen ihrer strafe warten auf eine
verlegung in eine vollzugsanstalt oder
sitzen in ausschaffungshaft
die nationale kommission zur verhütung
von folter lobt in einem bericht
explizit den respektvollen umgang mit
insassen indes bemängelt sie die
infrastruktur auch diesen spazierhof der
zu klein sei zu dunkel
hier begegnen wir auch häftlinge seien
wieder eingefangen gespräch
[Musik]
hier bleiben möchte auch rl der mann der
seine frau verloren hat er will die
restliche strafe von drei monaten im
regionalgefängnis bern absitzen obwohl
es in einer anderen anstalt komfortabler
wähle
[Musik]
das
einzige motor co
richtig bunt
[Musik]
rn rechnet damit bald frei zu kommen und
eine sozialarbeiterin bringt ihm gute
neuigkeiten es geht um einen mietvertrag
aber
draußen haben sie das nicht werden sie
angst ich habe keine angst
um meine gute leben erfahren gefreut
wenn
sie gewinn nicht so stark wie jetzt aber
der zivi viele positive sache gelernt
wie diese gefängnis wo ich habe keine
angst
außerdem sagt die liga zog ihm am
telefon mit versorge ich gut leben sagt
messi
exklusiver seele
marlies panda 60 jahre alt geschieden
mutter zweier kinder und seit kurzem
stolze großmutter
in ihrem gefängnis trifft die chefin
auch auf üble gewalttäter wie begegnet
sie diesen gefangenen sie antwortet mit
der geschichte einer begegnung mit einem
kinderschänder
und
abitur hier weitere von promis und
schützer nach und wenn er das nicht kann
der mmv czapla
zwischenfälle
ganz sicher nicht aber es ist notwendig
sie dass er wusste wie ich denke das ist
wichtig sie nicht als 1 mio die sie zur
sanierung zu sondern erhält müsse wisse
wenig über sie die tat danke
am späten nachmittag die disposition ist
überfordert noch 20 neue häftlinge
werden an diesem tag erwartet und
verschiedene gefangenen wollen in eine
neue zelle
zudem braut sich im vierten stockwerk
etwas zusammen ein häftling droht die
zelle zu zertrümmern in einem anderen
gefängnis hat er bereits batterien
verschluckt um verlegt zu werden
chefsache
ich kann nicht atmen hier drin ich bin
krank
aber sie haben ein großes zimmer das bis
zwei personen ist
ich kann nicht atmen
die disposition macht hier die zimmer
einteilung und nicht sie
sie kommen hier hin und sagen ich will
dass ich will jenes
sie machen überall probleme
wissen sie was ich in meinem bauch habe
ich habe batterien geschluckt
jetzt kommt diese geschichte damit
können sie mir nicht kommen das sagen
alle für mich sind das drogen
sind drogen
man hat immer die selben probleme mit
ihnen ich habe diese drohungen sagt
ja ja ich
kann hier nicht atmen
sie können schon ab ich frage jetzt mal
die disco
also das ist
einfach cool wie schon im spiel
ist
das ist nicht mehr doktor ich bin es
bitte ich bin in mein land
ja wir sind dran
nein jetzt will ich die zelle wechseln
ich möchte die medizin absetzen um clean
nach hause zu gehen
ja sie haben es gesagt
ich habe die anfrage schon gestern
morgen gemacht
maurice panda pendelt ihn und her
zwischen kleinen erfolgen und große
ernüchterung
entmutigen lässt sie sich nicht trotzdem
allem gewisse erlebnisse nach
dass sie schon bis wo man halt die
osterberger und das kann ich nicht
akzeptieren
mit probierens beste zu machen um die
wbc das internet die batterie geschlüpft
und hat schon in einen anderen klang ist
gemacht hätte ich bedauere jetzt kommt
zu mir sie packte jetzt liegt das land
im
auto sitze im kontext dienstag andrea
vier meter
die direktorin ist sich bewusst dass sie
mit ihrer art auf dem schmalen grat
balanciert zwischen zuckerbrot und
peitsche zwischen nähe und distanz
die
haut itu sich bemüht vor mir für cu
ich habe wichtig dass wir die richtige
höhe fliegt das richtig
abgrenzen
die stanz die stammt ist ganz wichtig
und das ist ein kulturmedium rg bayern
wirklich gezwungen da so die
mitarbeitenden
mit insassen
zugelassen
und liegt nun
1 opfern stimmt es
dass schwarz sagt ich habe natürlich
nicht sauber also einmal
bezeichnet unser mich freut
das ist ja egal wo man das
catering betriebe für sehr schön und
nett frau ich habe vergessen sagen sie
sind wunderbar und sie haben sehr
schönes augen man mit liebe grüße um den
stars so imponiert dass er muslimen
überhaupt erst möglich machen
ihr leben 135 verbrecher auf engstem
raum das nötigste wird ihnen gegeben
eine zelle zu essen zu trinken ein
fernseher gar
[Musik]
aber das wichtigste wird ihnen genommen
die freiheit nur ein wort verdiente sie
hat für den der 23 stunden am tag
eingesperrt ist kann es eine tortur sein
in dieser welt immer nur das schlechte
den menschen vermutet kann etwas
menschlichkeit nicht schaden
[Musik]